[Music]
the ethical world showed its fate and
it's truth to be the spirit that it
merely passed away in it the individual
self this legal person however has it's
substance and fulfillment outside of
that world the movement of the world of
culture and faith does away with this
abstraction of the person and through
the completed alienation through the
ultimate abstraction substance becomes
for spirit at first the universal will
and finally spirits own possession here
then knowledge appears at last to have
become completely identical with its
truth for its truth is this very
knowledge and any antithesis between the
two sides has vanished
vanished not only for us or in itself
but for self consciousness itself in
other words self consciousness has
gained the mastery over the antithesis
within consciousness itself this
antithesis rests on the antithesis of
the certainty of self and of the object
now however the object is for
consciousness itself the certainty of
itself that is knowledge just as the
certainty of itself as such no longer
has ends of its own is therefore no
longer contained within a determinate
here in paragraph 596 Hegel is taking us
into a new section which is called
spirit that is certain of itself
morality and before we go into these
introductory paragraphs at the very
beginning of this third main part of the
spirit portion of the work let's stop
for a moment and talk about these two
terms ethics or ethical and morality and
moral because I want to get a prevalent
[Music]
misunderstanding and miss reading out of
the way right at the beginning I will
probably have to stress this at a number
of points throughout this this entire
commentary on this section in ethics or
the study of right and wrong good and
bad moral norms however you want to
conceive of it we often make a
distinction between ethics on the one
hand and morality on the other and we
use these terms ethical and moral along
with that distinction now here's where
the problem arises many people make that
distinction
many people make at different ways so
for example in an Anglophone
introduction to ethical theory textbook
you may find the author saying something
like morality is simply the codes by
which we live it's not particularly
thought out it's not reflective it's
just you know what we've inherited from
our culture from parents from
institutions like school Church etcetera
etcetera
and ethical refers to what has really
been thought through what has been
consciously reflected upon and that's
the discipline of ethics that we're
going to begin doing now so if you adopt
that point of view you have almost the
exact opposite
of what Hagel himself has in mind in
using these terms it gets a little bit
more complicated as well by the fact
that ethical is really a translation of
a German term zit Lika you know coming
from zit in' which you know is a
translation or or a cognate you might
say in in some sense to Athos right but
also to morays so all these terms get
really mixed up and it's very important
when we're thinking about a particular
author that we look at what that author
is actually saying how they're using
these concepts and distinctions so for
Hegel the ethical is really more like
what a culture gives you it's what you
have by virtue of participating in that
culture taking on the roles that you
have inherited or been assigned find
yourself in there is certainly room for
improvisation and and you know doing
more than merely what a code Hegel never
uses the word code actually but a lot of
other people later on will use that
there's room for doing something that
goes beyond the code but it remains
hardest you could say to that
perspective and we saw this earlier in
the spirit section so this is a great
place to go to the text right here Hegel
is giving us kind of a summary of the
path that we've traversed he says the
ethical world showed its fate and it's
truth to be the spirit that had merely
passed away in at the individual self
great what's the ethical world that he's
talking about there in the earliest
parts of the spirit section we had that
whole discussion and all these
interesting dialectical transform
Asians of the you might say the family
or the gods right the divine law and
then the human law and the human
institutions that went along with that
and the clash between them we saw Hegel
using Sophocles Antigone as an example
of this but there are so many other
great examples as well that work just
fine for us this is a problematic that
we can still see happening today but
that was at the beginning of the spirit
section and we saw that where did it
culminate in what Hegel is calling here
the legal person and and you remember
that section the legal person culminated
in the Lord of the world and a kind of
universal alienation except for the Lord
of the world and even he or she wasn't
entirely content with with their their
status so we have an unresolved
problematic that actually didn't begin
there if you remember even further back
it was starting to emerge in the reason
section in those last two parts of it
once we got past the you know observing
reason and physiognomies and all that
other stuff and we got into discussion
of you know virtue and the law of the
heart and you know reason giving laws to
itself all of that business led us into
this this ethical world and what we've
got there is a lack of fulfillment
consciousness does not truly find itself
either in the institutions of the
ethical world or through the individual
who is attempting to traverse them so he
says this legal person has it's
substance that's a term that he's going
to use quite a bit in this and the
following paragraph substance and we'll
come back to that and fulfillment
outside of that world the true meaning
of it is not within that ethical world
so what do we transition to next
we get the world of culture and the
world of culture turns out to be you
know there's this long complicated
dialectic of the noble and base
consciousness and wealth and state power
and finally a kind of sophisticated
attitude of ironic detachment sort of
insanity that goes along with that
similar to that of skepticism right and
we have a state that's in some respects
similar to but also different from the
unhappy consciousness it cannot realize
itself so there's an alienation going on
there and what is the ultimate remedy
for that well it's it's faith and
insight and for a long time faith
dominates and provides some sort of
alternative and these are a world you
could say beyond the merely ethical
world and these are not new worlds as if
you like step from this world into this
world rather they inter penetrate each
other just as did the world in the
discussion about the the world of
perception the inverted world and then
the world of the laws and essences in
the early section in the consciousness
portion of the work force in the
understanding so these are worlds that
are adding greater and greater
sophistication to what's going on here
he says the movement of the world of
culture and faith does away with this
abstraction of the person and then he
talks about another transition through
the completed alienation through the
ultimate abstraction
what's this completed alienation and
ultimate abstraction well we passed
through the Enlightenment which is going
to be critical both of culture and faith
and of the previous ethical and we
eventually wind up at the point of
absolute freedom where knowledge and
will turn out to be
the same thing alright and he says that
through this now here's that term again
substance becomes for spirit at first
the universal will and then finally
spirits own possession so what do we
mean by substance here put aside
conceptions this will be helpful for you
at this point put aside conceptions of
substance as that out of which
everything is made or anything along
those lines and think rather in terms of
that which is going to be most relevant
most important what is holding our
attention think of substance as like
essence phase in this case and substance
by itself unless it's becoming subject
doesn't have full agency and isn't
conscious of itself and yet it is that
in which things you could say have their
play reside now this is sort of like the
earlier conception of substances Lucia
you know the the substance as subject of
predicates but we also wanted as the
subject of the agency and we want
substance to be aware of itself
so he says substance becomes for spirit
the first the universal will and then
finally spirits own possession and then
he says here knowledge appears that last
have become completely identical with
its truth and that raises an interesting
question we talk about knowledge of the
truth and then we're treating the truth
as if it's something out there and our
knowledge is a relation of ourselves to
that truth and that's the way it is for
many things you know the track is white
ok I got a look at the chalk is it white
yep Dwight you look at the track right
now there's a truth and we could say
well the truth is actually in though
those proposition
Shen's or something like that but I mean
Inglewood there's an earlier conception
of truth or the truth is also in the
thing and its relations to other stuff
so why would knowledge and truth then
coincide because it's knowledge of the
self knowledge of the self as rooted in
all of these dynamics so he goes down
and he says it's truth is this very
knowledge and any antithesis and here
the the word that's being translated as
antithesis is Gagen Zots any
contradiction any true opposition
between these two has vanished
now here Hegel says something really
interesting it's not only vanished for
us or in itself right and these were
these two categories that Hegel uses all
the time in contrast with each other
being in itself being for itself or for
another but notice at this time he
doesn't say for itself being in itself
and for itself he says being in itself
and being for us what do we have beyond
that not in place of it but beyond that
he says any antithesis any contradiction
between the two sides has vanished
vanished for us so it has vanished for
us vanished in itself important there
but also for self consciousness itself
Szell's Babu signs Elst right there's a
repetition there an intensification so
he says now here gets even more
interesting self consciousness has
gained the mastery over the antithesis
within consciousness itself that is the
dialectical advance that has taken place
in the absolute freedom section and now
leading us into this morality
I almost said morality play and it
really is a play in many respects as
you'll see in the later paragraphs but
in this morality section
this dynamic that's taking place here so
he goes on and he says this antithesis
rests on the antithesis of the certainty
of self and of the object now he says
the object is for consciousness itself
the certainty of itself knowledge just
as the certainty of itself as such no
longer has ends of its own is no longer
container than in determinist but is
pure knowledge what does all this mean
in this new attitude of morality
remember spirit through self
consciousness has truly become conscious
of what it is and it's its extricated
itself in an ideal way not necessarily
you know given the actual person that
that I am or it is in that place but
it's extricated itself from all of these
ways of identifying itself and it's
grasped itself as universal and the
other as equally Universal this opens up
the possibility for what Hegel now is
calling morality morality tense and I'd
mentioned that we needed to think beyond
the ethical as simply you know what
we're inheriting from our culture
adapting in certain ways morality is
going to be more universal for Hegel and
because of that there's also going to be
an alienation involved but I'm
foreshadowing and saying that so a lot
of transitions here and now we have to
see what else he has to tell us about
this new section
thus for self-consciousness its
knowledge is the substance itself this
substance is for it just as immediate as
it is absolutely mediated in an
indivisible unity it is immediate like
the ethical consciousness which knows
its duty and does it and is bound up
with it as with its own nature but it is
not character as that ethical
consciousness is which on account of its
immediacy is a specifically determined
spirit belongs only to one of the
ethical essentiality and he has the
characteristic of not knowing it is
absolute mediation like the
consciousness which cultivates itself
and the consciousness which believes for
it is essentially the movement of the
self to set aside the abstraction of
immediate existence and to become
conscious of itself as a universal and
yet to do so neither by the pure
alienation and disruption of itself into
the actuality nor by fleeing from it
rather it is immediately present to
itself in its substance for this is its
knowledge is the intuitive pure
certainty of itself and just this
immediacy which is its own reality is
all reality for the immediate is being
itself and as pure immediacy purified by
absolute negativity it is being in
general or all being
paragraph 597 is further developing this
distinction between the ethical and the
moral here in this section on spirit
that is is certain of itself morality so
how is it certain of itself it has to do
with its grasp of not only itself but
but it's its grasp of the other and its
relation to it within a kind of
overarching community so he says for
self-consciousness its knowledge is the
substance itself that's worth dwelling
on it's knowledge is the substance
itself so it's not as if you simply have
a substance that then became self-aware
at least in part and it's sort of
picturing itself to itself no there's
there's a relation of you might say self
transparency as it understands what it
is it takes on a substantiality you
could say so he goes on and he says this
substance is for it just as immediate as
is it is absolutely mediated in an
indivisible unity so it's both immediate
and mediated at the same time and you
might say big deal everything that we've
ever seen in the dialectic up till this
point that we think is immediate turns
out to be mediated at the same time
right there's always this this let's put
it out there immediate all right since
certainty boom there's some immediate
there's some mediation going on there
the universal right well in this case
it's aware of itself as both immediate
and mediated that's an important
difference so he goes on and he says it
is immediate like the ethical
consciousness the ethical consciousness
knows its duty and does it now of course
we're forgetting all of the other twists
and turns
in which it kind of wavers and tries to
get a little bit of stuff for itself put
all that aside for the moment this is a
little bit of an idealization but we've
got an ethical consciousness and this
arises at many different points
including in the reasons section
including even going all the way back to
the master-slave dialectic if the slave
is taking on the character of slave or
something along those lines it's finding
its meaning within the ethical substance
there was a term that Hegel used quite a
bit which essentially is the community
and its workings so he says it's
immediate like the self the ethical
consciousness which knows its duty so it
knows that and does it and is bound up
with it as with its own nature but it
meaning the moral consciousness is not
character as and so this is really key
that ethical consciousness is why on
account of its immediacy it is here
here's the key idea it is a specifically
determined spirit mind Geist
belongs only to one of the ethical
essentiality x' we're gonna come back to
that and has the characteristic of not
knowing it doesn't grasp the totality it
doesn't grasp itself as anything more
than a moment of a larger system it can
in fact get things wrong and think that
it is the main show as we see happening
with state power or we see happening
with you know the the alienated
individual within culture right but it
doesn't grasp how it fits in with the
other ethical we can call them
characters or the other agencies within
the ethical substance we also have the
problem that antitheses arise or
contradictions arise between different
representatives of the ethical substance
you know the conflict between wealth and
state power between the noble and
ignoble consciousness prime example
earlier on the conflict between the
human and divine law between the family
and the state all of these are case in
points where what should be one unified
ethical substance is turned against
itself and to have character means
lining oneself up for one against
another the moral consciousness is not
like that why not okay so here is where
this this this importance of knowing
itself comes in all right
he says the moral consciousness is
absolute mediation how so he clarifies
like the consciousness which cultivates
itself and the consciousness which
believes so the consciousness which
cultivates itself was a consciousness of
culture the building section the
consciousness which believes that would
allow right faith he says it's
essentially the movement of the self to
set aside the abstraction of immediate
existence what was there in the ethical
and to become conscious of itself as a
universal now here's where there's
something different here's where
something has been achieved through the
absolute freedom section yet to do so
neither by the pure alienation and
disruption of itself and of actuality
what happened in the culture section nor
by fleeing from it right nor by doing
for that matter any of Enlightenment's
analogues to that there are just as many
dead ends to the dialectic in the
Enlightenment section as there are in
the faith section as there are in the
culture section if we proceed through
and come out on the other side then we
arrive at this point where moral
consciousness becomes possible he says
so he says it's immediately present to
itself in its substance for this
substance what it is what a grass itself
has is this knowledge
it is the intuitive pure certainty of
itself and just this immediacy which is
its own reality is all reality for the
immediate being the immediate is being
itself and as pure immediacy purified by
absolute negativity says it is being in
general or all being now do we have to
pass through the French Revolution in
order to make this possible probably not
if you think for example about the
methodology that is involved in both the
rationalist and the empiricist tradition
it's a looking at what is there within
the self and it's its consciousness and
you see this culminating in [ __ ] very
clearly in both the first critique which
is about speculative or as it calls it
pure reason and even more so in the
second critique here's all I'm gonna say
about this at this point what we've got
here is in Hegel talking about this you
know absolute knowing of itself
immediacy you know in mediation I
grasped myself as a human being as such
like you and I can speak for both of us
because you're also permitted to speak
within this moral community and we work
out this is going to sound very Hobart
Massey and we work out norms we work out
what ought to be the case by thinking
about what what does in fact include and
apply to it incorporate both of us and
we do so in a way very different than
that of the ethical where everybody has
their their assigned place and function
and character and this we ought to all
be substitutable for each other this is
how you get to something like Kant's
categorical imperative all right or any
of the other things that are analogous
to it in moral theory
you
absolute essential being is therefore
not exhausted when determined as the
simple essence of thought it is all
reality and this reality is only as
knowledge what consciousness did not
know would have no significance for
consciousness and can have no power over
it into its conscious will all
objectivity the whole world has
withdrawn it is absolutely free in that
it knows its freedom and just this
knowledge is its substance and purpose
and its sole content
paragraph 598 ends this short
introductory section to the morality
part of spirit which is you know going
to be about another 70 odd paragraphs
quite a lot of the work if you think
about the fact that the the
phenomenology of spirit actually only
has a little over eight hundred
paragraphs
Savan D is really the the length of the
preface
so it's you know about 1/12 of the
entire work so this is an important
section and Hegel is bringing together
some of the threads that he's laid out
I'd mentioned in in the earlier
paragraphs that we want to think about
this in terms of essence not just
substance and here he actually uses the
term essence Miller translates it as
essential being but it's just Vaes in'
in in the german right absolute two V's
and he says absolute essential being is
not exhausted not just you know emptied
out when determined as the simple what
again essence of thought the vision of
thought says it's all reality and this
reality is only as knowledge now here's
where you can see Hegel's idealism
showing but but this is not an idealism
that starts from idealism as a axiom or
something like that this is saying that
the world just as at the beginning of
observing reason right and then the
other reason parts this is what it means
for human consciousness to develop it
sort of devours the world and
incorporates it and makes it its own so
he says it's all reality all of your
cleek kite and this reality is as
knowledge so he says what consciousness
did not know would have no significance
for consciousness and can have no power
over it now that's rather optimistic and
you might say well what about
unconscious you know desires or
something like that you know you might
bring up depth psychology
well when you
bring them out don't they become
conscious in a way yes and they get
sucked into the realm of thought and we
can go on and on and on with examples
like this so he says into its conscious
will now notice he's using that term
we'll there we are dealing with the
practical realm not just a realm of pure
speculation or of science understood as
this you know way of making sense of the
universe and perhaps afterwards applying
technology this is driven by a will so
well this will come back and further
paragraphs into its conscious will all
objectivity the whole world has
withdrawn he says now it's a free will
it is absolutely free says in that it
knows its freedom and he says just this
knowledge is its substance and its
purpose and its goal content what does
that mean
once again spirit as self consciousness
has found itself in a particular new
state or shape Gestalt of consciousness
and it's being presented with that and
now it has to figure out great this is
in front of me I know something about
myself what the hell does this all mean
that is what it's going to be figuring
out as we move now into the next portion
of this section of the work
you